[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au programme de l'actualité des
infos pratiques et des idées de sortie
voici le programme de ce 30 janvier
alors que le projet de loi sur la
réforme des retraites est étudiée depuis
aujourd'hui en commission à l'Assemblée
nationale une nouvelle journée de grève
est prévue demain une mobilisation à
terre-professionnelle à l'appel des 8
principaux syndicats qui laissent
présager des perturbations dans
plusieurs secteurs à quoi faut-il
s'attendre notamment dans les transports
et les écoles le point dans cette
édition
tout au long du mois de janvier période
traditionnelle des vœux TV 78 reçoit les
maires de 50 ans en Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de l'année 2023 dans
leur ville ce soir focus sur Maurepas
reconstruction et de la halle du marché
rénovation des écoles carrefour de la
malmedone à quoi faut-il s'attendre le
maire de la commune Grégory garestier
notre invité
et puis une équipe féminine sur route
pour le Vaisse SkyTeam vous sert le Vélo
Club d'Élancourt 50 ans en Yvelines la
présenter ce mois-ci elle démarrera sa
saison en National 2 quels sont les
ambitions nous posons la question au
président de l'équipe Thierry Fabre et à
l'une des coureuses loup de l'aise
et ce sera dans la page sport avec vous
Nicolas dandry bonsoir bonsoir vous
n'êtes pas Mickey l'ennemi de vous
remplacez Michaël et ce soir pour les
résultats sport notamment de quoi
va-t-on parler ce soir on va parler du
carton plein des clubs de rugby et
Vinois ce week-end coup de faiblesse du
basket Yves Linois aussi et puis on va
aller découvrir aussi les futurs
championnes et bien du tennis puisque il
y avait la Winter Cup à Feucherolles ce
week-end on en parlera tout à l'heure en
face de vous deux invités qui sont avec
nous dans la deuxième partie mais ils
ont ils sont déjà avec nous Kevin et
Guillaume Torin bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes frères et on vous avait suivi il y
a quelques années pour votre périple
cette aventure ce tour du monde à vélo
qui devait durer trois ans mais qui a
été malheureusement stoppé à cause du
covid 19 deux ans plus tard vous vous
apprêtez à repartir le départ est fixé
au 9 février on parlera du parcours tout
à l'heure mais pourquoi repartir qui
viennent on considère qu'on n'est jamais
vraiment rentré surtout quand ça s'est
interrompu aussi brutalement et de
manière assez imprévisible quand même
avec ce covid donc repartir parce que on
doit finir cette aventure quoi il y a un
engouement Guillaume là on est à une
semaine du départ
on rassemble le matériel on vérifie nos
vaccins on est on est sur les
préparatifs l'itinéraire on regarde tout
ça mais là on a on a hâte on a hâte de
commencer et on va parler de cette
itinéraire dans un instant ce sera dans
la deuxième partie de cette émission
avec nous également Céline Charles
bonsoir de la rédaction de TV 78 les
informations du jour à suivre avec vous
dans un instant il y aura aussi de la
musique au menu de ce 7 8 avec la Pieta
l'artiste sera sur la scène de la Merise
ce vendredi à Trappes et à l'ouvrira la
soirée avant le concert de Skip The Use
mais avant tout cela coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
et demain matin le ciel devrait être
clair dans les Yvelines avec peut-être
quelques rayons de soleil il fera un
degré à Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans 2 degrés
à Versailles et 0° à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi même condition annoncées au
niveau des températures comptées 7
degrés à Versailles ou dans 6 degrés à
Rambouillet et 8 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ce mardi 31 janvier
dernier jour de ce mois de janvier nous
fêterons les Marcel
les informations de ce lundi 30 janvier
avec vous Céline Charles et la colère
contre la réforme des retraites bat son
plein dans les Yvelines et oui alors que
se poursuit demain le mouvement social
contre la réforme des retraites on le
sait d'autres actions se sont déroulées
ces derniers jours dans les Yvelines
parmi elles une retraite au flambeau
organisé vendredi soir à Rambouillet le
cortège est parti de la caserne des
pompiers à 18h45 équipé de lampion
lampes frontale et torches et ses
dirigés jusqu'à la gare au total environ
130 manifestants étaient présents une
nouvelle marche aux flambeaux aura lieu
le vendredi 3 février à Rambouillet
ainsi que dans quatre autres villes des
Yvelines avis maintenant au passionné de
musique le Centre de Musique Baroque de
Versailles ouvre ses inscriptions pour
le recrutement des pages exactement
Grégory les inscriptions sont ouvertes
pour la rentrée de septembre 2023 les
pages se sont des élèves de 7 à 14 ans
en classe à horaires aménagé qui suivent
un cursus de chant et de formation
musicale de haut niveau cette formation
permet aux enfants d'intégrer une
véritable troupe vocale et de se
produire en concert par la suite tous
les enfants actuellement scolarisés du
CP au CM2 peuvent s'inscrire au concours
d'entrée attention par contre le dépôt
des candidatures doit être effectué
avant le vendredi 17 février
l'inscription se fait en ligne via le
site internet de l'école elle est
revenue ce week-end c'est la braderie du
groupe asmodel s'est tenue samedi dans
les locaux de l'entreprise a Guyancourt
alors à ce modèle c'est une entreprise
spécialisée dans les jeux de société à
l'organiser une grande opération de
déstockage dans son entrepro à
Guyancourt ce samedi cette grande
braderie propose un large panel de jeux
de société à prix réduit une journée de
convivialité ou petit grand ont pu
trouver leur bonheur écouter venez
profiter du de la braderie Asmodée pour
trouver des jeux petits prix et pouvoir
les offrir et pouvoir jouer aussi avec
d'autres personnes alors on a pris tic
tac boum pour les enfants donc du Junior
et un peu plus vieux parce qu'on a des
enfants plus jeunes un camel up et puis
un peu plus de jeux pour les enfants
encore là-dedans c'est l'occasion de
créer des liens avec les gens de la
commune de partager avec des joueurs de
partager avec des familles des bons
moments de jeu tout simplement et de
leur faire profiter d'un prêt attractif
alors à noter que toutes les recettes de
l'opération vont être reversées à
l'association bouche et cœur de
Guyancourt une association d'aide
alimentaire aux personnes en difficulté
à présent c'est la police des Yvelines
lance un appel pour retrouver les
propriétaires d'un lapin égaré et oui
c'est sur la voie publique de
Sartrouville qui a été retrouvée ce
lapin de couleur marron il attend donc
ses propriétaires au commissariat de la
ville si vous avez des informations
aussi vous reconnaissez votre animal
vous pouvez contacter le commissariat au
01 30 86 56 56 et on termine ces
informations par un peu de légèreté vous
pouvez d'ores et déjà réfléchir à vos
messages d'amour pour la Saint-Valentin
plusieurs villes des Yvelines les
diffuseront en grand le 14 février sur
les panneaux lumineux de la ville vous
avez déjà la possibilité d'écrire vos
mots doux à plaisir et Bois d'Arcy par
exemple plus d'informations sur les
sites Internet des communes
je sais pas si ma commune fait ça mais
on va voir est-ce qu'il y a des
déclarations d'amour à faire aussi du
côté de Kevin et Guillaume
mais vous serez déjà loin mais en tout
cas le message envoyé quand même un mot
merci Céline pour toutes ces
informations et si vous aussi près de
chez vous vous êtes témoin d'un fait
d'une information qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas le dire sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
et elle a une de l'actualité on vous le
disait dans les titres le mouvement de
grève se poursuit en France après
l'annonce de la réforme des retraites et
du report de l'âge légal à 64 ans l'âge
de départ un âge légal qui est
d'ailleurs plus négociable à annoncé la
première ministre Elisabeth borne alors
demain mardi une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation est organisée par les
syndicats quoi faut-il s'attendre dans
les Yvelines avril Gontier fait le point
avec Patrick Jacques de Dixmude après la
grève du 19 janvier contre la réforme
des retraites les syndicats appellent à
une nouvelle mobilisation massive ce
mardi conséquences de nombreuses
perturbations sont à prévoir dans les
transports plusieurs lignes seront
impactées comptez intrins sur 3 pour la
ligne u 1 sur 10 pour la ligne N la
ligne J et la ligne L les RER A et B
seront également perturbés les syndicats
de l'éducation seront également
mobilisés ce mardi le 19 janvier 62 %
des écoles étaient grévistes dans le
primaire les syndicats de l'éducation et
des lycéens ont appelé dans un
communiqué à un mouvement encore plus
fort pour le 31 janvier du côté de la
santé la CGT santé et action sociale
annoncent continuer la mobilisation ce
mardi 31 janvier ce lundi 30 janvier
l'Inter syndical départemental était
réuni devant la préfecture des Yvelines
à Versailles pour rencontrer le préfet
l'objectif de cette rencontre symbolique
faire remonter les revendications
locales à l'échelle nationale
que ça se décide en revanche le préfet
en tant que grande commis de l'État est
fondée à recevoir nos réclamations et à
entendre notre détermination et à la
faire remonter à au gouvernement parce
que l'idée c'est qu'effectivement
partout dans les départements en plus de
cette internation de cette
intercendicale nationale en plus du
travail dans les secteurs les
fédérations etc il y a un travail dans
les territoires pour montrer que
l'opposition à la réforme des retraites
elle est résolue elle s'encre au niveau
local profondément
également de montrer l'union entre les
différents syndicats il fallait qu'on
montre aujourd'hui
aux habitants de des Yvelines que les
syndicats étaient tous ensemble et je
voulais aussi nous voulions aussi que le
préfet sache que tous les syndicats
étaient bien là ensemble aujourd'hui
c'est également ensemble qu'ils se
rendront mardi à Paris dans les Yvelines
des bus sont prévues pour rejoindre le
départ du cortège notamment à
Rambouillet et à Mantes-la-Jolie une
mobilisation qui devrait perdurer des
descentes aux flambeau unitaires sont
organisés le 3 février dans de
nombreuses villes Yvelines
et ce projet de loi de réforme des
retraites est étudiées depuis
aujourd'hui en commission à l'Assemblée
nationale 7000 amendements ont déjà été
déposés dans ce contexte d'opposition
des syndicats et peut-être même avec une
poignée de députés de la majorité qui
pourrait voter contre le texte un solo
non au contraire de France Info une
semaine qui risque donc d'être agité
pour le gouvernement écouter à ce propos
Jean-Noël Barrault il est ivinois et
ministre délégué à la transition
numérique et au télécommunication il
était ce dimanche à Manille les hameaux
pour ses vœux il s'exprime au micro de
Gabriel Gontier je ne souhaite
évidemment pas qu'il y ait de blocage je
souhaite que le débat puisse avoir lieu
sur ce projet de réforme des retraites
qui va commencer à être examinées cette
semaine au Parlement il est de notre
responsabilité de la responsabilité de
notre génération de transmettre à la
génération qui viendra après nous un
système de retraite par répartition qui
fonctionne qui est équilibré le même que
celui dont nous avons hérité de la
génération qui nous a précédé qui a
libéré la France et qui après la
Libération a conçu la la sécurité
sociale qui fait qu'il fait aujourd'hui
si bon vivre en France mais nous
proposerons un entretien plus long avec
Jean-Noël Barraud dans nos éditions du 7
8 de cette semaine avec nous à présent
visioconférence Grégory garestier le
maire de Maurepas bonsoir
bonsoir également vice-président de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines on va parler
avec vous de l'année 2023 qui s'annonce
pour votre commune des grands projets
qui pourraient voir le jour pour cette
année je vous fais juste réagir à ce
sujet d'actualité cette nouvelle journée
de grève demain à contre la réforme des
retraites à quel point va tel impacter
votre commune et service de votre
commune et comment justement la commune
de Maurepas s'organise-t-elle avec cette
journée qui se qui se profile
écoutez déjà je vous souhaite une belle
année à chacun d'entre vous sur le sur
le plateau merci de me recevoir merci à
vous également merci il est vrai que on
s'organise pour demain on a un service
minimum d'accueil dans l'une de nos
écoles qui va pouvoir permettre
d'accueillir les familles qui ont besoin
malgré elle est quand même impacté alors
on a moins de grévistes que la journée
du 19 janvier qui pour le moment est
déclaré mais ils ont pas l'obligation
vous le savez de ce déclarer avant le
cas demain mais en tout cas en proposera
nous une ouverture des services publics
et mes services minimum d'accueil pour
permettre aux familles qui en ont besoin
de pouvoir faire accueillir leurs
enfants et donc nous verrons demain
comment ça se passera si le moment est
beaucoup plus fluide que la précédente
alors 2023 s'ouvre aussi dans un
contexte compliqué pour les communes
pour l'ensemble des Français vous les
avez rappelé d'ailleurs dans l'édito du
magazine de Maurepas de ce mois de
janvier une guerre en Europe qui ont
entraîné une crise énergétique une crise
économique alors face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie il y a la solution de
la sobriété énergétique qui s'impose
dans le dans les communes comment
a-t-elle été prise en compte à Maurepas
et ce qu'il y a des prévoyez de faire
des choses cette année en matière de
sobriété énergétique
alors je dirais que l'avantage aussi
qu'on a sur le territoire de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin c'est
que bah en communique beaucoup entre
nous et qu'on travaille beaucoup entre
nous et qu'on sait coordonné avec
l'ensemble des mers et que nous avons
mis en place il est surtout axé sur
l'extinction de l'éclairage public qui
nous permet de faire des économies qui
est très bien excepté d'ailleurs par nos
habitants c'est aussi la bête des
températures dans les équipements
publics dans la limite évidemment de ce
qui est permis par par les décrets donc
un petit changement d'habitude mais qui
est accepté par nos habitants ils
comprennent évidemment cette volonté de
faire des efforts et en même temps de
protéger
l'environnement et puis la planète et
c'est aussi un changement de de
mentalité avec peut-être une perspective
aussi nous nous engageons dans les
travaux que nous présentons dans nos
établissements c'est à dire les passions
LED par exemple on a accéléré la
transition en l'aide de nos éc une
phrase de nos équipements publics pour
faire des économies d'énergie c'est 30%
à peu près l'économie d'énergie parce
que
il est vrai que c'est un contexte très
compliqué pour les collectivités
déjà subi en 2022
et donc
c'était quand même une somme importante
il faut qu'on continue nos efforts mais
pour autant
j'ose espérer que la situation ne va pas
durer parce que je ne sais pas comment
on va pouvoir ensuite
j'allais dire tenir l'équilibre de nos
budgets scientifia nous n'avons pas
pour faire face cette augmentation
exponentielle de l'énergie que nous
n'avions pas prévu alors la connexion
n'est pas très bonne en excuse auprès de
nos téléspectateurs alors sur cet angle
de la rénovation énergétique il me
semble qu’à mort pas il y aura un
engagement cette année en tout cas la
définition d'un projet pour rénover les
trois écoles du centre-ville c'est bien
ça c'est c'est
dans vos projets
oui alors depuis que je suis devenu en
2014 on a lancé un grand plan de
rénovation de nos bâtiments communaux on
en a à peu près 55 donc l'attaché lourde
et nous avons déjà rénové quelques
écoles et nous allons continuer
notamment les trois plus grandes écoles
où la plus grande école de Maurepas de
l'école de la même me donne qui est
associé à l'école de la haute vitesse et
de descente c'est quoi le matériel comme
c'est l'école de la même donne l'école
qui est déjà suffisamment
qui accueille plus de trois élèves nous
avons l'ambition d'engager des travaux
de rénovation
et aussi dans une réflexion de
transformer l'une des écoles maternelles
en école élémentaire donc là on a lancé
les études de faisabilité et nous avons
déjà engagé des concertations d'élèves
sur ce sujet donc on démarre j'allais
dire l'ambition mais c'est une ambition
qui va se dérouler sur plusieurs années
en contenu du coût de restructuration de
ces trois écoles et d'agrandissement
également il y a un autre dossier dont
on parle depuis 2019 dans la commune de
Maurepas c'est bien sûr cette du marché
on se rappelle qui a été détruite par un
incendie en juillet 2019 il y a une
phase de concertation qui avait été
lancée pour décider de la construction
d'une nouvelle halle qui est-il prévu du
coup cette année est-ce que les travaux
de cette nouvelle halle vont pouvoir
démarrer
oui alors ils vont commencer en 2023 on
a perdu un peu de temps sur le dossier à
cause j'allais dire de l'inflation du
coût des matières premières dont on est
aussi victime dans nos marchés publics
du marché en fait évidemment les frais
donc c'est très attendu par nos
habitants et par nos commerçants pas mal
de consultations vous l'avez rappelé
donc début des travaux espérés avec une
livraison prévue en 2017 ont une halle
qui fera la place belle au bois aux
énergies renouvelables avec récupérateur
d'eau de pluie avec panneaux solaires
des états commerçants qui seront
pérennes puisque c'était l'une de leur
volonté également les halles du marché
construit aujourd'hui n'ont rien à voir
avec celle du passé donc beaucoup plus
de confort un confort visuel un confort
en termes aussi
j'allais dire de circulation d'air bref
tout est pensé pour que on est un
centre-ville et une loi du marché
beaucoup dynamique et beaucoup plus
attractive qu'auparavant donc ça avance
Nicolas dandry qui est avec grand
plateau vous aviez une question une
question puisqu'on parle de commerce il
y a les halles de Maurepas pour les
commerçants les vendeurs et les
maraîchers mais parlons des espaces
commerciaux un peu plus grands notamment
Paris Ouest ce que vous partagez aussi
avec la commune de Coignières le forum
JB cette zone commerciale est-ce qu'il y
a des nouvelles étapes qui vont qui vont
intervenir en 2023 alors je sais que ça
concerne la commune de Maurepas mais
c'est aussi plus globalement
l'intercommunalité de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est
concernée
oui vous avez raison alors la zone
d'activité Paris Ouest que nous avons en
commun avec la ville de Coignières nous
avons mené avec l'aide de l'État à une
étude sur ce qu'on appelle repenser la
périphérique commerciale qui a débouché
sur un schéma directeur de développement
qui n'est pas si simple parce que en
fait les valeurs foncières qui sont
quand même très importantes sur le
secteur et plus de 180 propriétaires
différents donc du côté de Coignières on
a cette volonté la redignanisation du
forum du gibet et du côté de Maurepas ce
qu'on appelle le programme éthicien là
où s'est installé cultura s'est installé
également de nouveaux Kiabi et là on a
un projet aussi d'extension et de
revalorisation des espaces commerciaux
existants avec de nouvelles enseignes
aussi qui vont arriver dans des locaux
et des espaces qui sont beaucoup plus
tournés aussi vers le développement
durable et beaucoup plus qualitatif donc
une zone commerciale et industrielle je
le rappelle qui est en pleine évolution
mutation c'est une zone d'activité qui a
été créée il y a plus de 50 ans et donc
voilà ça fait petit à petit et en effet
elle se redynamise au fil du temps et on
s'y est-elle avec le maire de punir
puisque vous parlez des zones
commerciales on le sait en bordure de
nationale 10 j'en profite pour parler de
ce sujet de circulation il y a un point
central un que vous partagez avec les
communes justement de Coignières mais
aussi de la verrière c'est ce carrefour
de la malmedone en 2019 Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines avait lancé un projet de
réaménagement et cette année c'est une
enquête publique qui est prévue sur sur
le sujet on va avoir du concret aussi
dès cette année 2023 on imagine un
projet peut-être un peu retardé aussi
avec le covid-19
oui vous avez raison parce que ce projet
a été annoncé auprès des habitants je
crois que c'était en 2019 et puis une
concertation préalable en à cette
période là rien ne s'était passé depuis
donc aujourd'hui c'est mené par la
Direction des Routes donc l'état en
collaboration évidemment avec le 50e
ligne la région Île-de-France le
département des Yvelines et donc c'est
un vrai projet structurant pour pour nos
communes avec une enquête publique qui
va commencer d'ici le printemps
donc évidemment la ville de Maurepas est
favorable avec nous l'espérons aussi
quelques ajustements avec notamment les
deux activités qui sont Bordes qui
bordent la nationale 10 et qu'il faudra
justement à terme déplacé mais sinon
c'est un projet vraiment très utile
parce que ça va permettre la réouverture
de l'axe départemental la départementale
13 pour permettre aux habitants
d'accéder directement à la gare de La
Verrière donc un projet structurant qui
en a bien besoin qui était en tout cas
quand il y en a bien besoin pour
revitaliser ce secteur et pour mieux le
sécuriser et en tout cas mieux sécuriser
les accès et repenser aussi j'allais
dire les mobilités douces qui
aujourd'hui est un pas écoeuon amorpa
également côté circulation une
reconfiguration du boulevard miserait
pour cette année 2023
oui tout à fait on parle de circulation
du boulevard miserek est
qui poursuit le carrefour des pyramides
qui va verser en cours donc un boulevard
qui
j'allais dire connaît à peu près 9000
véhicules par jour donc c'est pas le
plus structurant qu'on comparé au
boulevard de la Loire qui est plutôt à
16000 véhicules par jour mais qui était
un boulevard qui est on le voit sur les
photos qui est surdimensionné donc on va
le passer en deux fois une voie on va y
recréer des places de stationnement le
long du centre médical des pyramides qui
lui est en train de s'étendre avec
l'arrivée d'une IRM dans quelques
quelques mois et puis c'est aussi de
retravailler les espaces paysagers de
replanter des arbres bref un aimant plus
qualitatif avec une pacification de la
circulation avec les différents usages
que l'on connaît avec la mobilité douce
les vélos les trottinettes les piétons
donc voilà ça fait partie du panel de
tous les travaux que nous menons sur le
territoire de Maurepas
il y en a d'autres on va reconstruire
aussi du centre de loisirs primaires et
le seul centre de loisirs primaires de
Maurepas qui n'avait pas connu de
travaux depuis 1983 donc là on détruit
reconstruit totalement avec un bâtiment
qui soit tourné vers le développement
durable également sur le même site donc
voilà nous avons déjà répondu à près de
67% de notre projet de mandat sur les 85
mandats sur lequel j'ai été rayures 2020
on a déjà atteint un taux de réalisation
de lancement de 67% juste avant qu'on
passe à l'interview Express qu'il exerce
classique que l'on propose aux maires
durant ce mois de janvier un projet
original aussi qui va avoir le jour à
Maurepas c'est celui d'une microforêt
urbaine qui va pousser le long de la
nationale 10 c'est dans le score de
l'Estérel dans le quartier de la joue
les habitants les écoliers la mairie
vont planter des arbres des arbustes il
y a d'ailleurs un rendez-vous qui
organisé pour les habitants le 11
février à 10 heures pourquoi ce projet
quel est l'intérêt de porter un tel
projet dans votre commune
oui alors c'est un projet qui nous tient
à quoi à coeur parce que l'équipe
municipale on est déjà mobilisé depuis
de nombreuses années sur le
développement durable et la protection
de l'environnement on a créé des espaces
paysagers on a restructuré des espaces
publics en y plantant des arbres on a un
projet de 500 arbres sur le mandat on a
également mis en place et planter des
vergers participatifs et d'autres
actions je veux pas vous en faire toute
la litanie ce soir mais en tout cas
cette microforêt c'est une nouveauté sur
le territoire de Maurepas on s'inspire
d'une méthode japonaise c'est un projet
qui est piloté par ma première adjointe
Myriam debuquois et on avait un espace
qui était
inutilisé depuis nombreuses années en
bordure de national 10 protégé par un
mur anti-bruit à proximité très proche
des pavillons et à la place d'une
ancienne de station-service désaffectée
donc le terrain est totalement dépollué
on a à peu près 1300 mètres carrés près
de 1950 arbustes et arbres pour que
d'ici 20 ans ça soit suffisamment dent
pour que ça soit
donc ça va être un niveau de fraîcheur
ça va être capteur de carbone également
et on est à ce dossier avec référence
fun qui est une association qui milite
justement pour
forêt et c'est
sponsorisé par l'entreprise panthère
donc c'est autofinancé totalement pour
un coup de 27 500 euros non seulement ce
coûte rien mais en plus c'est bon pour
la planète des arbres donc voilà c'est
une belle opération et on va engager
des plantations avec les enfants des
écoles et puis les habitants de Maurepas
qui voudront
pour terminer cet entretien on passe à
l'interview express
[Musique]
Grégory garissier je vais vous poser 5
questions c'est des questions que nous
avons posé à l'ensemble des maires de 50
ans en Yvelines qui sont venus dans ce 7
8 en plateau alors une exigence des
réponses courtes oui un nom un pour ou
contre suffisent parfois une explication
mais je vous demandais pas dépasser les
20 secondes d'explications sur sur ces
questions première question Grégory
guerrier 2023 vous augmenterez les
impôts locaux à Maurepas
alors à l'heure actuelle rien n'est
prévu encore à ce stade on prépare les
arbitrages
certaines communes ont fait le choix de
passer une imitation de 30 km/h pour
leurs axes est-ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre une telle idée
je pense que le 30 km/h s'applique dans
certaines zones c'est utile voire même
10 km/h parfois mais sur la totalité de
la commune non il faut déjà faire
respecter le 5 dans d'autres communes
également dans certaines communes on a
fait le choix de passer à des cantines
bio est-ce que vous êtes pour ou contre
l'obligation du bio dans les cantines
peut-être une incitation du lieu dans
les cantines
alors c'est une bonne question et c'est
déjà obligatoire vous savez c'est 20% de
bio prévus par la loi égalim et 30% de
produits issus des circuits courts donc
j'allais dire ça l'est déjà de facto à
20% et c'est un coup c'est une rotation
de 30 de 20% du coup du repas si tu
trouves on devait tout passer audio et
pour être plus précis on a aussi une
problématique de production de terre bio
de très agricoles bio donc faudrait
qu'on soit aussi en capacité de
d'acheter en tout cas des produits bio
si on devait passer à 100%. donc déjà
respectons la loi Agadir aujourd'hui qui
a quand même des des conséquences et qui
n'est pas si simple en termes de
d'objectif européens on a vu dans
l'actualité malheureusement des mères et
des élus qui ont été victimes
d'agression de menaces est-ce que vous
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions vous
avez déjà eu peur physiquement
je n'ai jamais eu peur physiquement mais
parfois il est arrivé qu'en un moment
plus tendu que d'autres notamment quand
j'ai eu affaire par exemple des
occupations illicites de terrain mais ça
c'est toujours très très bien passé
parce que évidemment pas que il faut
qu'on soit un peu formé dans le dans
l'exercice et les élus chargés de
l'embellissement de la ville qui a eu
affaire à une agression physique parce
que elle avait des elle avait repéré un
une personne qui avait déposé des
déchets sauvages sur la République
et il y a eu l'agression physique donc
elle a déposé plainte et donc mais ça
fait partie aussi des contexte il y a
quand même de plus en plus violente ou
les barrières
lâche et donc il faut quand même très
attentif d'ailleurs la société des
maires de France on dénoncer qu'on avait
une augmentation
physique Warren berbal
près des mers je le regrette mais en
tout cas personnellement moi je ne l'ai
jamais vécu
mais pour autant voilà on est quand même
très attentif à ce qui se passe et
des maires de France est-ce que oui ou
non Grégory Garcia vous êtes un maire
heureux
ah oui totalement et je viens de
terminer mes réunions de quartier avec
les morpasiens à la suite de
l'annulation des vœux du maire dans le
cadre de notre plan de sobriété
énergétique et financier
de les morts pasiens sont contents
évidemment il y a toujours des choses à
régler et heureusement mais s'ils le son
je le suis aussi et j'ai toujours la
même façon et depuis que je suis maire
depuis 2014 donc oui et 100% oui merci
Grégory Garcia d'avoir été avec nous je
le rappelle mère de la commune de
Maurepas une nouvelle fois très bonne
année dans votre commune
merci à tous merci à vous et on ouvre à
présent une page port dans ce 7 8
[Musique]
avec deux invités qui nous ont rejoint
on va parler de cyclisme dans un instant
cyclisme féminin mais avant tout Nicolas
la page sport aussi des résultats les
résultats sportifs du week-end on parle
de football américain pour commencer
effectivement Grégory alors il n'y a pas
une match officielle entre les Templiers
d'Élancourt et les caïmans les caïmans
du monde oui c'est ça alors pas au sens
c'est au sens propre hein pas au sens
figuré parce que la raison il y a une
irrégularité au niveau de l'équipe
médicale du match par rapport à la
réglementation de la Fédération
française de football américain les
Templiers concètent donc une défaite sur
tapis vert néanmoins les deux équipes
ont joué un match d'entraînement ce
samedi 28 janvier et c'était l'occasion
pour le quaterbach américain Ashley
Brooks de fouler le synthétique du
complexe de l'Europe des encours sous
son nouveau maillot des Templiers on
passe au tennis et un bon résultat pour
notre Yves Linois Arthur hinders
d'Australie le Saint-Germain s'est
rattrapé en double il a réussi à se
hisser jusqu'en quart finale de la
compétition avec son compère Benjamin
Bonzi la perte Tricolore s'est incliné
face au duo polonais monégasque Yann
zilenski et Hugo Nice le score 6-4 et
c'est une grande première pour Arthur
rindernech qui n'avait jamais atteint un
quart de finale du Grand Chelem un bon
parcours pour lui en Grand Chelem même
si c'est en double on attend un bon
parcours en simple il y avait aussi du
football ce weekend oui championnat de
National une le FC Versailles a été tenu
en échec par le Puy foot au stade
Jean-Bouin le score imbu partout les
Versailles avaient pourtant bien
commencé avec l'ouverture du score dès
la troisième minute mais les auvergnates
n'ont rien lâché et ont égalisé à la 78e
minute aucun changement au classement
néanmoins les joueurs de la cité royale
reste leader de national avec 33 points
devant Martigues deuxième avec 32 points
prochain match ce vendredi 3 février
Versailles ira dans l'Ain à
Bourg-en-Bresse du rugby à présent et
oui rugby alors là c'est
complètement la folie le rugby noir est
en réussite dans le championnat de
fédéral nouvelle victoire pour plaisir
un succès bonifié 47 à 25 face à Amiens
avec un total de 7 essais inscrits par
les plaisirsois devant son public du
côté du stade de porschefontaine
Versailles s'est imposé de justesse face
à Ris-Orangis à la 80e minute grâce à
une pénalité de son arrière Baptiste
floraux score final 27 à 25 au
classement les plaisirs restent toujours
à la deuxième place Versailles pointant
sixième position place qualificatif pour
les phases finales on espère des bonnes
nouvelles en basket non peut-être c'est
un peu plus compliqué c'est pas la folie
dans le championnat national 3 de basket
et mettre rap c'est incliné sur son
parquet face à Chartres 64 à 69 les
trapis sont 7e au classement à égalité à
égalité de points avec le prochain
adversaire et leur prochaine adversaire
c'est Orléans trap se déplacera là-bas
pour une rencontre de chocs ça sera
samedi 4 février au pays des châteaux de
la Loire du basket féminin oui alors
tout comme l'équipe masculine de Trappes
les chaînesiennes de l'Entente le Chênée
Versailles on concédé une défaite à
domicile 58 60 face à Calais au
classement les aiguinois se font doubler
par leurs adversaires du soir et par les
Bretonnes du Trégueux langue basket et
d'ailleurs direction la Bretagne samedi
prochain pour les basketteurs
basketteuses pardon de l'Entente Le
Chesnay Versailles elles iront défier
les rainaises tennis féminin avec un
gros événement dans les Yvelines et un
gros événement est beaucoup de
championne futur championne du vendredi
26 jusqu'à hier dimanche les meilleurs
jeux du tennis européen âge tennis
européen
âgé de 15 à 16 ans se sont affrontés à
Feucherolles un week-end qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre des fascanificatives pour
la Winter Cup entre 8 nations la
République tchèque a remporté cette
étape à Feucherolles la France a terminé
s'inquiètes cinquième et on écoute tout
de suite Francis Evia qui est le
président du comité des Yvelines de
tennis à propos de la Winter Cup c'est
une compétition importante pour le
comité puisque ça rentre dans notre cas
de formation au niveau le comité des
Yvelines et un centre de formation
régionale mais aussi
pratiquement national puis on a des
meilleurs nationaux notamment Antoine
guibodo qui est dans les 15 meilleurs
monts junior mondiaux on a la championne
de France de tennis fauteuil qui
envisage de participer aux Jeux
olympiques ou paralympiques de 2024 donc
pour nous c'est l'image du tennis du
haut niveau mais c'est aussi ça sert
pour le développement auprès des jeunes
voir ce niveau de Jump puisque à 16 ans
beaucoup de ces jeunes filles sont
pratiquement déjà sur le circuit
professionnel
donc ça ça donne des envies au niveau
des jeunes
prochaine étape pour cette Winter Cup ce
week-end au Portugal il y aura ensuite
deux autres étapes en Turquie et en
Suède les deux meilleures équipes de ces
quatre phases de qualification se
retrouveront fin février à Brest et on
va parler à présent de cyclisme Nicolas
avec le Vélo Club d'Élancourt 50 ans en
Yvelines vous sert de représentants nous
ont rejoint en plateau parce que en ce
mois de janvier a été présenté à
l'équipe féminine sur route qui va
démarrer en National 2 et pour en parler
donc Thierry Fabre bonsoir et Louis
Delhaize Thierry Fabre président du BCE
Sky Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et l'une
de ces cyclistes donc Louis dolles
pourquoi voir voulu créer cette équipe
féminine sur route Thierry il y a
plusieurs raisons la première au club on
a une piste de haut niveau avec pour qui
vont faire les Jeux Olympiques on a une
une section handisport également on a
une école de vélo et ce qui nous
manquait c'était
des femmes qui faisaient du cyclisme
mais donc on a décidé de ouvrir une
équipe nationale en recrutant des
cyclistes de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à
côté et des cyclistes qui avaient de la
qualité sur le territoire national et du
coup est-ce que ça a été compliqué à
monter cette section pas vraiment
non non non
ça pas été compliqué il y a la volonté
il y a l'envie il y a le soutien des
partenaires financiers la société vous
sert et puis on s'est aussi réunis avec
les directeurs sportifs
et Philippe papaye pour se décider sur
un choix un profil de femmes qu'on
voulait que nous on les voulait
courageuse
volontaire avec un bon état d'esprit et
on s'est refait à 10 jeunes filles qui
venaient toute la France et bien de
l'Est de Lyon d'Annecy donc loup gauche
toutes les cases et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'on l'appelle notre couteau
suisse parce que elle est mise à part sa
qualité de cycliste elle a vraiment un
très bon esprit vous vous retrouvez dans
ces termes courageux bon esprit et puis
volontaire oui bien sûr en fait je
concilie sport études et j'ai à la fois
un emploi civique au club donc en fait
je vais m'occuper de l'école de vélo
tout simplement de VTT
et oui justement en fait Thierry a
construit cette dn avec des valeurs et
en fait toute l'équipe est ambitieuse
donc oui ça me convient très bien alors
loulou vous avez 20 ans est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter un peu votre
histoire quand est-ce que vous avez
commencé le cyclisme alors j'ai commencé
le cyclisme sur piste en premier lieu en
2019 ensuite j'ai commencé à faire un
peu de route parce qu'évidemment il faut
entre guillemets prendre la caisse et
j'étais toujours toute seule en fait
j'étais dans des clubs avec plus
d'hommes que de femmes et en fait là
Thierry a construit une dn uniquement
féminine donc là je me suis dit c'est
l'occasion il faut que j'y aille il faut
que je teste et au moins je ne serai
plus toute seule donc là ça me motive
encore plus à aller courir dans toute la
France avec l'équipe c'est ça qui vous a
poussé à rejoindre l'aventure
qui est de plus en plus de féminisation
de votre club de ces dernières années
c'est une volonté on imagine d'aller
vers plus de cyclisme féminins d'avoir
des sections oui on a commencer par
handisport avec Eric Castaldi qui est
sur Bull sur son projet handisport il a
il a fait rentrer des des femmes des
femmes des jeunes filles dans le section
handisport et ça m'a ça m'a plu parce
que c'est quand même un beau partage
entre les hommes et les femmes et je
voulais absolument que
qu'on donne la chance à des femmes de
découvrir le haut niveau et c'est pour
ça que j'ai monté cette équipe parce que
je voyais d'où était toute seule la râle
allemande et julietteur Aublin était à
Marmande et ils habitaient sur
Saint-Quentin il fallait absolument que
je puisse les retrouver en sur des
valeurs du sport c'est ça c'est leur
donner un encadrement finalement parce
que malheureusement le cyclisme féminin
peut-être encore un peu passé développé
en France là on voit notamment au niveau
national le Tour de France féminin qui
commence à à se faire une une place mais
c'est de leur donner un encadrement
imaginez on s'est on a amené des
des bénévoles de chez nous en formation
pour devenir entraîneur on a recréé
recruté aussi un entraîneur l'extérieur
et puis on a des quand même des gros
moyens logistique officiel qui ne vous
sert grâce à ce que vous sert on a quand
même de véhicules d'accompagnement un
véhicule qui est offert par Skoda parce
que là on a deux autres véhicules on a
beaucoup de partenaires qui ont cru en
nous et c'est grâce à eux qu'on est
quand même motivés vous ambitions on
voit l'ambition du club présenté par
Thierry mais du coup vous vos ambitions
qu'elles sont-elles c'est un jour
peut-être faire Grégory en parler le
Tour de France féminin ou peut-être les
Jeux Olympiques ouais c'est encore un
petit peu c'est trop proche pour le
moment donc comme je l'ai dit en fait
j'avais commencé toute seule donc je
pars un peu de rien j'avais jamais fait
de j'ai encore jamais fait de saison
route complète donc cette année ce sera
plus une année de formation et après
dans les années futures on verra comment
on va progresser comment l'équipe va
progresser les profils vont se
spécialiser donc là on pourra parler un
peu plus sérieusement mais pour le
moment c'est une découverte vous votre
profil moi je suis plus puncheuse donc
c'est à dire que je vais aller chercher
les échapper pour mon équipe pour
emmener les rouleuses dans l'échapper
dans la bonne échappée et les emmener
pourquoi pas au sprint final est-ce que
vous avez un modèle un cyclisme féminin
non pas vraiment une inspiration non pas
vraiment non alors c'est une équipe
assez jeune Thierry on parle de loups
qui a 20 ans il y a également Lara qui a
18 ans Juliette Roblin qui a qui a 19
ans on parlait du mot Jo 2024 il est
encore peut-être un peu tôt pour en
parler ici il est dans un coin de la
tête
on a cette chance on a trois chances un
c'est l'équilibre avec une jeune fille
comme Coralie Boo qui a 17 ans toutes
les autres filles Océane de mangent
Anaïs en disant Schmidt en 18 ans
et
Adrien la Torres à 18 ans aussi lou à 20
ans Lara à 18 ans Juliette à 18 ans et
il fallait absolument que je puisse
recruter une capitaine de route
et on a recruté au CNTC qui était
professionnelle de l'année dernière à
Aubert elle a 27 ans elle va encadrer
nos jeunes pour plus on est et on a
surtout la hallement
qui lui est qui vient d'être embauché
par le Service Départemental d'Incendie
de secours pour un emploi de haut niveau
qui elle Lara est en équipe de France
sur piste ou pour la Saint Quentin et
l'école en équipe de France a été
champion du monde junior l'année
dernière de poursuite par équipe et on
espère en croiser droit qu'il y a eu au
jeu à Paris mais si ce n'est pas les
jeux à Paris ce sera les futurs
l'objectif c'est d'atteindre la
nationale vous êtes en National 2 là
actuellement c'est le premier objectif
ouais 14 équipes en France en National
on est la seule équipe dans les unes a
été au niveau national que ça soit femme
ou à mon cyclisme notre objectif cette
année c'est de finir dans les cinq
premières équipes il y a une première
raison la première c'était de qualifier
au championnat de France élite qui se
disent ce gros long à Cassel au mois de
juin et deuxième c'est
rêver monter sur une accession nationale
une première compétition la loupe pour
vous
comment se déroulera le 12 mars ce sera
la première Coupe de France en fait
cette année
où les en Seine-et-Marne
c'est une dernière question oui sur
parce qu'il y a des étapes de Coupe de
France mais il y a aussi des tours c'est
ça un détour à Étaples cette étape du
Tour de France on va de coupe de
Françoise des principes on a été invité
au Grand Prix de Fourmies avec les avec
les courses élites on fait le tour de
l'Orne on va faire le tour de l'Est dans
les Vosges pour honorer Océane demain et
Anaïs Schmidt parce que c'est leur terre
et puis on va essayer de faire aussi
pour le tour de l'homme parce qu'il y a
Pauline
Pauline elle est de Pauline et de là-bas
et donc on va essayer de faire des
courses sur le territoire des jeunes
femmes qui sont licenciés chez nous pour
leur faire honneur pour les mettre dans
la lumière et ce type de course l'eau
pour le coup c'est des nouveautés c'est
tout nouveau pour vous ce type de course
j'ai encore jamais fait je vais goûter
mais je pense que ça va être ça va être
très sympa merci lou merci je vous
souhaite plein de réussite dans ce
projet qu'on va suivre bien sûr avec
attention pour pour la suite des
événements on poursuit avec du tri après
une information sur le triathlon oui
c'est un retour aux sources pour Léonie
perio après avoir évolué 10 ans sous les
couleurs de Poissy la triathlète de 28
ans a décidé de revenir au club de
Versailles là où tout a commencé la
sportive Illinoise préparera avec la
structure les prochains Jeux olympiques
de Paris en 2024 elle espère il
décrocher une médaille d'or après avoir
remporté le bronze en relais mixtes aux
JO de Tokyo cyclin d’œil du Paris
Saint-Germain dans les Yvelines jeudi
dernier on n'a pas les habitudes on n'a
pas l'habitude de les voir comme ça mais
l'équipe du PSG a visité le futur centre
d'entraînement à Poissy en tenue de
chantier et bien l'occasion pour
l'ensemble du groupe parisien ben de
voir l'avancée de ce chantier donc vous
voyez un Mbappé Messi ou encore Neymar
avec leur petit casque de chantier la
livraison de la structure et programmée
dans le courant de l'année 2023 il
comprendra 17 terrains de football des
hébergements à un restaurant ou encore
un spa
première devrait s'y entraîner à partir
de cette idée une séquence sportive
comme on les aime pour terminer je
suppose que vous allez apprécier cette
séquence c'est un extrait d'un reportage
réalisé par Julien Leroy le dimanche 15
janvier dernier l'as Pontigny affronté
le RC et Paris 15 au Parc des Sports
Roger Couderc de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
c'est du rugby et il s'était immergé
dans les coulisses de la préparation
physique et psychologique des
montaigneuses une équipe de rugby
féminin c'est leur surnom elles sont tes
news je peux vous le dire vous allez le
voir entre stress concentration et
détermination portrait d'une équipe
soudée malgré la défaite regardez
alors tu vas commencer par fermer les
yeux
prendre trois bonnes respirations
inspire
ou expire et fait monter ce niveau de
joie ce niveau d'enthousiasme à
l'intérieur de toi
ressens le là maintenant ressort cette
énergie dans tes pieds dans tes mollets
dans tes cuisses dans ton ventre ressent
cet enthousiasme portons attention sur
les bruits les sons comment l'énergie
tourne dans ton corps
reste connecté à ça et dans cet espace
visualise toi en match là maintenant
inspiration expiration
[Musique]
et à ton rythme tu peux réouvrir les
yeux et garder cette énergie jusqu'au
bout du match
en numéro 1 du coup lol
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai confiance en vous ayez
confiance en vous et tout se passera
bien merci
de toute façon avec le vent les filles
va faire qu'on se colle au cul va pas
falloir qu'on s'éloignant il va falloir
qu'on colle ensemble et qu'on colle à ce
de score elle met en essai il va
falloir qu'on soit de morte de
faim on soit on s'en fout on répond on
répond direct mais il va falloir qu'on
aille au combat les meufs il va falloir
qu'on y aille tout ensemble et quand on
rentre sur le terrain si on est
remplaçant c'est qu'on est mort de faim
allez on mérite
[Applaudissements]
parce que là ça va être un match
difficile parce que même s'il fait beau
il y a beaucoup de vent donc les pattes
j'ai pas qu'elles arrivent pas et elles
sont voilà elles sont elles sont quand
même pas mal Paris 15 donc voilà il y a
du stress mais je sens l'équipe super
motivée là vraiment il y a une bonne
ambiance tu sens comment tendu mais ça
va ça va le faire
il reportage complet à retrouver sur nos
réseaux sociaux d'ici la fin de la
semaine ils sont revenus en plateau
Kevin et Guillaume Torin l'aventure
eybro on en parlait tout à l'heure elle
a été stoppé le 23 avril 2020 à cause du
covid vous mettiez fin à votre tour du
monde à vélo et vous avez décidé de
repartir repartir à l'aventure ce sera
le 9 février prochain on se souvient
2020 le périple avait été stoppé au
Pérou là vous repartez de Turquie
pourquoi repartir de Turquie
déjà on s'est pas mal de temps posé la
question d'où repartir est-ce que on
voulait reprendre à partir de l'Amérique
du Sud comme faire une continuité mais
il y avait déjà cette envie en Amérique
du Sud de quitter un petit peu
l'Amérique parce qu'on est resté quand
même un an parce que on a fait quand
même de nombreux allers-retours
notamment sur la cordillère on a une
petite tendance à aimer les la haute
altitude et
une autre route nous a intéressé quand
on a révoqué le départ en tout cas quand
surtout le covid c'est un petit peu
calmé on a on a pensé à la route du
Palmyre qui est une route aussi en
altitude en haute montagne donc il y
avait le choix de commencer par la
Mongolie
mais au mois de février il fait très
froid donc du coup on va prendre on va
se réchauffer un petit peu on va rester
un peu aux choses sur des températures
comme en France donc en Turquie en
direction en direction de la route du
Palmyre et du coup Guillaume on peut
parler de suite de l'aventure ou là on
repart sur une nouvelle aventure comment
comment vous vous placez ou par rapport
à ce nouveau voyage c'est une nouvelle
aventure mais qui a une continuité quand
même ce qu'on va aller visiter un
nouveau continent continuons asiatique
donc on le voit
on le voit plus comme une nouvelle
aventure ce que mine de rien bon bah
faut se repréparer faut redire au revoir
c'est c'est
on recommence
vous allez être dans le même état
d'esprit aussi entretenir un certain
contact avec les personnes que vous
allez rencontrer les locaux aussi des
pays que vous allez traverser c'est sûr
qu'on a alors ce qui nous portait
énormément à coeur très bonne mémoire
depuis toutes ces années les rencontres
c'était très important on a vécu
vraiment des choses extraordinaires sur
sur le voyage et notamment je pense
grâce à ce moyen de locomotion et ce
voyage assez lent en fait cette manière
de voyager assez lente qui nous permet
d'aller dans des villages où on s'y
arrête pas spécialement je pense quand
on fait un traitant en moto ou en
voiture du coup oui c'est toujours
quelque chose très important je pense
qu'en plus on va gagner beaucoup
d'expérience mine de rien sur deux ans
de voyage de comment rencontrer ça
paraît bête quoi mais à l'époque nous on
savait pas trop toquer aux portes alors
qu'on avait déjà fait des voyages à vélo
mais on n'avait pas ce réflexe on était
plus en mode autonome avec notre petite
tente et en fait au bout d'un moment
mais on a appris on a tout simplement
appris à une chose toute bête
pour nous tous mais simplement demander
quoi et à partir de là oui on va enfin
ça fait vraiment partie du cœur de notre
projet c'est les rencontres avant tout
donc la dernière fois le parcours on se
souvient sud de l'Europe il y avait
l'Afrique après l'Amérique latine
Amérique du Sud et là ce sera l'Asie du
coup cette fois-ci quel est votre
parcours est-ce qu'il est déjà établi il
est il est établi alors après il va se
dans les détails on verra on verra sur
place parce que mon nous on a établi
avec nos contacts et puis notre
expérience mais c'est surtout sur place
et on va nous dire bon bah passer par là
pas par là donc comme sur le premier
voyage l'itinéraire il va changer mais
là oui on va passer par la Turquie la
Géorgie ensuite il y a les herbaïdjan on
va traverser donc la mer Noire la mer
Caspienne donc ça c'est pareil il va
falloir trouver une embarcation
pour pour la traversée puis ensuite on
classait tous les pays qui s'unissent en
Kazakhstan bekistan Tadjikistan
voilà il y a toujours l'objectif de 80
km par jour c'était l'objectif fixé
encore une très bonne mémoire
mais en fait c'est marrant parce que
tous ces objectifs chiffrés on les a mis
parce que quelque part on nous demande
en fait de combien est-ce qu'on va c'est
des questions qui revenaient
régulièrement combien de kilomètres
est-ce qu'on va faire par jour combien
pèse nos vélos donc beaucoup de chiffres
quoi donc bon à ça nous on y a posé 80
parce que c'est un petit peu la routine
qu'on avait quand on pédaler
aujourd'hui je sais pas c'est un
objectif parce que quand c'est plat on
est capable de faire plus je crois qu'on
a même fait 160 une journée dans le
désert du Sahara facile
sur une moyenne mais quand on est sur
des montagnes vous doutez bien que si on
arrive à faire 80 c'est bien pour nous
mais c'est pas cher
allez-y Nicolas un mot quand même sur
les pays que vous allez traverser
qu'est-ce que vous attendez à voir parce
qu'on sait que c'est des pays qui sont
peu connus qui sont très désertiques
vous attendez à quel type de paysage
quelle population aussi parce que
peut-être que la population n'est pas
forcément habituée à voir des étrangers
justement c'est ça que ça qu'on
recherche et les déserts les montagnes
parce que il y a il y a moins de monde
on peut passer plus de temps à
contempler il y a aussi moins de monde
sur les routes enfin c'est là où on se
retrouve le mieux dans un voyage comme
ça à vélo c'est quand on est seul ou en
tout cas avec très peu de monde c'est
aussi comme ça qu'on peut aller au plus
proche des familles et puis avoir des
échanger des moments ça peut être un
sourire dans la rue mais ça peut être
aussi autour d'un repas chez eux donc
c'est ça qu'on recherche dans dans ces
pays c'est justement ce qu'on a tracé on
a vraiment visé les les montagnes et les
déserts sur ce sur cette itinéraire avec
beaucoup de haut il y a aussi forcément
des bas alors si on se souvient de la
première aventure aussi vous étiez fait
voler votre vélo Guillaume dans une
auberge à Lisbonne pour repartir il a
fallu s'en procurer un nouveau le
rééquiper alors chose incroyable il a
été retrouvé ce vélo ça c'est incroyable
je voulais vous en parler il a été
retrouvé depuis votre retour en France
en fait alors ça en effet c'est une
histoire incroyable improbable je pense
parce que je sais pas si vous vous êtes
déjà fait voler un vélo mais moi pas mal
de fois et bon on les retrouve jamais en
plus on a eu des histoires commune de
vélo de vélo volés dans le coin bon ben
on les retrouve difficiles à chaque fois
ben là c'est à Lisbonne qu'on se le fait
voler et c'est deux ans plus tard un an
et demi plus tard
qu'on a un petit message sur Instagram
comme quoi la petite magie des réseaux
sociaux des fois et une personne a cru
voir en fait notre notre vélo et de là
il y a eu une petite enquête assez
rapide et là encore Facebook a généré
des contacts des relations et on a
réussi à remettre la main dessus c'est
incroyable par deux personnes qui
étaient qui parlaient français qui
étaient à Lisbonne et Guillaume a pu
retoucher son vélo qui faisait partie
avec du coup oui il a déjà roulé cet été
et puis bah là et ils ont cours de
préparation mais eux et là je repars
avec c'est quand même c'est ça c'est une
aventure qu'on pourra suivre sur les
réseaux sociaux de nouveau avec le lien
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran bah
merci Kevin et Guillaume et on va vous
suivre bien sûr au cours de cette
aventure Bonaventure à vous bonne
nouvelle aventure merci d'être passé en
plateau pour en parler on va refermer
cette émission en musique vendredi
prochain la Meurice attrape accueillera
le concert de Skip The Use le groupe de
rock lillois fait son retour sur scène
après deux ans d'absence et pour ouvrir
la soirée la Pieta sera sur la scène de
la Merise les artistes est actuellement
en tournée pour la promotion de son
dernier album Lyna Mola qui est sorti en
novembre écoutez son interview entretien
qui a été enregistré il y a quelques
jours
[Musique]
et donc la Pieta est avec nous en
visioconférence bonsoir
alors je disais vous êtes une artiste
musicale et même une hauteur puisque
vous mêlez la musique et la littérature
on va en parler la Pieta c'est un style
slam rock chanson pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne vous connaissent
pas qui est la Pietà
la Pieta c'est un projet que j'ai lancé
il y a 7 ans maintenant et effectivement
l'idée c'était que je puisse être
complètement libre artiste et moi j'aime
bien chanter mais j'aime bien écrire
j'aime bien faire de la photo de l'image
donc avec la Pieta je fais un peu tout
ça je réalise mes clips je fais les
visuels et puis effectivement j'ai créé
des livres et
je compose des chansons et en novembre
vous avez sorti votre nouveau projet qui
s'appelle Lina Morad on va écouter tout
de suite un extrait de l'un des titres
qui s'appelle une tempête
[Musique]
qu'il faut s'aimer beaucoup tant qu'il
est encore temps ça commence sûrement là
c'est un peu comme la vie ça bouleverse
ce soit droit mais ça reste joli je te
tiens tu me tiens dans la vie
le premier de nous deux qui est mort
une tempête donc qui est extrait de
votre dernier projet linamola ça veut
dire l'amoureuse en Italie puisque vous
questionnez sur l'amour pourquoi choisir
ce thème de l'amour
en fait je me suis lancée dans ce projet
en 2019 et je me posais plein de
questions sur la route parce que j'étais
seule depuis un moment tout simplement
et que je comprenais pas trop ce monde
des applications de rencontre etc et
surtout j'avais fait des ateliers avec
des personnes âgées dans un EHPAD et
quand il me parlait de leur vision à eux
de l'amour j'avais l'impression que
c'était très différent par rapport à
notre époque donc j'ai fait j'ai fait se
rencontrer des enfants des personnes
âgées j'ai interrogé mes fans interroger
plein de gens sur cette question de
l'amour et j'en ai fait du coup
effectivement un album qui vient de
sortir et un bouquin ça tient plus tard
on va en parler dans un assaut oui c'est
plus de deux ans de travail finalement
pour un album un livre également vous
l'avez dit vous êtes allé aussi
notamment la rencontre de plusieurs
personnes il y a eu tout un travail
préalable à l'écriture de ce livre et de
et de cet album
c'est ça ouais c'est ce que je disais
c'est un véritable travail de recherche
au départ j'avais l'intention de faire
tout ce projet en Italie puisque c'est
un pays auquel je suis particulièrement
attaché et je trouvais que ça
correspondait bien à cette notion
d'amour et de passion et puis en fait on
s'est retrouvé en 2020 et on était
confiné donc j'ai pas pu faire le projet
en Italie mais en fait ça m'a encore
plus interrogé sur la notion d'amour
puisqu'on était tous enfermés les uns
chez les autres donc je suis allée à la
rencontre des gens aussi de manière
numérique j'ai demandé à médecin de
m'envoyer des textes sur la question de
l'amour et effectivement c'est venu
nourrir disque et donc ce disque qui
aussi sera nourri d'un livre qui va
sortir cette année je le disais vous
mêlez musique littérature c'est deux
univers qui vous parlent justement
pourquoi les mêler pourquoi les les
passerelles sont aussi peut-être simples
entre les deux univers pourquoi les
mêlés
je pense que de toute façon c'est pas
très pas très très éloigné la chanson
c'est rien d'autre que un texte poétique
qu'on met en mélodie et en rythme donc
moi j'ai commencé la musique d'abord
parce que j'écrivais j'écris depuis que
je suis toute petite je commençais à
remplir des cahiers avec des textes
poétiques depuis mes 10 12 ans
et puis à l'adolescence vers 14-15 ans
je me suis dit que j'avais envie de
mettre en musique ces petits poèmes que
j'écrivais donc pour moi ça a toujours
été lié l'écriture et la musique quand
est-ce que le livre sortira
j'ai pas encore de date parce que je
suis en train de chercher un éditeur et
que du coup ça va dépendre de l'éditeur
mais j'aimerais bien que ça sorte vers
la fin d'année 2023 je pense et ça
s'appellera également linamola également
le même titre que l'album non pas du
tout
c'est un jeu de mots donc c'est lettre
elle apostrophe etre
et votre actualité donc il y a cet album
sorti en novembre le livre qui va sortir
prochainement et actuellement vous êtes
en tournée c'est ça c'est ça on est en
pleine tournée pour défendre l'album Les
lamorata sur scène cette tournée va se
s'étirer encore sur toute l'année 2023
on prend beaucoup de plaisir il y a
plusieurs formules de spectacles et une
formule le plus électrique c'est ce
qu'on va faire à trappe le 3 février
avec ce qu'ils veilleuse et puis il y a
une formule où on est que piano roi qui
est un peu plus se poser un peu plus
chanson et puis en parallèle je suis en
train de préparer un spectacle jeune
public c'est un spectacle qui sera sur
scène à partir de 2024 oui vous l'avez
dit le 3 février donc vous serez en
ouverture de soirée du de ce concert
avec ce type de use il y a deux concerts
dans une soirée une soirée rock là au
programme à la Meuse
ouais tout à fait c'est pour ça qu'on
vient avec la formule plus électrique
plus rock on aime beaucoup ça on a déjà
joué avec ce use on se connaît bien et
on le très content de pouvoir revenir
alors pour la petite anecdote le concert
était prévu en 2019 à la base il avait
été repoussé sur 2020 et puis il y a eu
le covid donc en fait on se retrouve
enfin et ce sera donc vendredi vendredi
3 février à la Merise un début du
concert à 20h30 vous avez le lien de la
billetterie qui s'affiche pour prendre
votre place merci la Pietà d'avoir été
avec nous
merci beaucoup à vous
[Musique]
et mercredi nous reparlerons de cette
soirée concert à la memorise avec Matt
Bastard le leader de Skip de husk qui
sera notre invité exceptionnelle voilà
c'est bientôt la fin de ce 7 8 mais
juste avant un dernier coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel devrait être clair
dans les Yvelines avec peut-être
quelques rayons de soleil il fera un
degré à Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan 2
degrés à Versailles et 0° à Rambouillet
dans l'après-midi même condition
annoncées au niveau des températures 7
degrés à Versailles et aux dents 6° à
Rambouillet et 8 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ce mardi 31 janvier ce
sera la sainte Marcel voilà c'est la fin
de ce 7 8 merci de votre fidélité on se
retrouve dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]